get up here I want to make sure all this
is my vlog you'll be on YouTube shortly
just so vlog real quick these are old
people to your skin
[Music]
I've been
thank you I know that if somebody here
started a podcast for this industry and
put out an episode every week and
interviewed a thought leader in this
industry that even though only seven
hundred and fifteen hundred people would
listen to it because it's obviously very
niche in its content that it would be
the differentiator of growing their
business that it would lead to lead gen
that there are people that they're
trying to chase to get the account that
in turn a year later would be chasing
them to be a guest on the show which
then would inevitably lead to them
getting the business my friends please
understand over the next period of time
as I talk to you about some of these
nuances that I am not a technologist
that had I not been in business that I
wouldn't want to have necessarily an
Instagram or snapchat or LinkedIn
account it doesn't come natural to me
it's not necessarily what I want what I
want is to sell stuff what I want is to
run a successful business what I want is
to win and to me if you sit in this room
and you do not realize how extreme the
internet technology revolution actually
is you become vulnerable watch this by
show of hands how many people here now
mainly watch Netflix or Amazon Prime for
what is called an OTT HB on the go
mainly those platforms raise your hands
actually please stand up please I mean
it I apologize I know you're lazy but
stand up I want people to see this I
want be if you make do not sit down yet
and honestly if you mainly watch Netflix
or Amazon Prime or Hulu or YouTube guys
I just need everybody look around I have
clients that are spending 80 built bath
and get up here get up here I want to
make sure all this is my vlog
you'll be on YouTube shortly just
so vlog real quick these are old people
right I mean this is 30s and 40s and 50s
and 60s and 70s look around literally
Jesus 87% of this audience doesn't even
have the chance to consume a commercial
and the 13% that are sitting that
watched Network when a commercial goes
on they grab this eighty billion dollars
spent on commercials in America and
nobody and I mean nobody is watching
cool thank you I really see that there's
so few people that take advantage of
what's out because a lot of people hear
that stuff and think it's more like the
secret like you just sit and you dream
it into existence it's got a very
interesting stigma listen I for example
as you know don't love positioning
myself as a motivational speaker even
the content you just saw but no question
the mindset is the operating system of
our lives
and I'm an absolute believer in cutting
out negativity going on the offense like
positive thinking like what's the
alternative
like practicality I'm a big believer in
that stuff but action is really the
biggest thing huh in happened and I do
believe that the right mindset leads to
the right actions so yes I do think
you've listened to me it's about getting
poison out of the system right right I
mean look
then we people use in your situation
yeah right because that's what they
decide to think about right you did it
right
the end right it's [ __ ] binary right
and so you know one of the things I do
often is
the people around me doesn't thinking
about negativity I'm like what's the
alternate and there's so much negative
[ __ ] out of people right you're positive
they're running around with their legs
and complaining right right so I'm with
you I couldn't agree more
yeah yeah I really appreciate real
pleasure Simon all right good to see you
brother I've been following you for many
many years by the exude Rosenbaum
r-really
Thank You Eddie that means a lot to me
Sarah you know you
I would love that fix your single on the
older side and that brother really it's
Mike it's a mindset brother where the
mind is where you do that's it that's it
thanks a real pleasure
take care so something to think about
I'm like yo bro cool like to me it's
like of course but I definitely think
June and July for
just drove from Nashville to Chattanooga
a beautiful day a bunch of calls with in
the office in New York kind of [ __ ] load
down on the phones shame with Mickey now
walking into the office here at a Manor
nuga it's a good thing how to give a
good keynote that battle his mom by
Bevin mouth and she won't get for rest
of the day love them vlog thanks for
watching really you know I I'm a big
believer that it's no different than
swimming or riding a bike to things that
didn't come natural to me I started
swimming and riding a bike late in my
life you know like I think I don't think
I started swimming if I was nine because
I feared that but the answer was
literally to just jump into pools or
swimming to just like skin your knee
right to take in a little water you know
I just think you do it like I just like
I think the best thing that could happen
to you is if you hear this advice
there's a networking event in town you
go you put on your nice little Manor
media Henle name tag you walk up you see
somebody you're inspired by in my five
minutes with Gary you go up and go hi to
John and John looks at you and says get
the [ __ ] out of my face I actually think
that would be the best thing that could
ever happen to you yeah I think the best
thing that can happen to somebody when
they fear something is for them to taste
the thing they feared aggressively and
immediately when they could try
something yeah I think that it just
eliminates like you'll literally be
there and whether you go crying in the
bathroom or just like becoming silent or
walking out of there or walking and
getting a you know a you know a
cheeseburger for five seconds and coming
back I think the great thing that would
happen to you is that you'd be like okay
well that app
now what like once people understand and
taste the thing they fear it becomes a
hell of a lot less scary where what
we're doing it there yep
and then this is not what I said in the
last time awake in real life I told some
guy like two months ago he look just
like and I couldn't you weren't sure if
it was him oh no kidding that's awesome
like I know I'm talking about me no I
don't
and now it's like I'm gonna think of
this guy's name and they love it I swear
it's like Facebook knows what you're
thinking about keep such a pleasure man
thank you brother take care of it I love
it Hans it put up snapchat I hope you're
doing your thing hope life is good
the flavors good it's about it oh you
put up everybody's brackets what's that
or brackets we did a bunch of random
wreck okay I love it it can become more
important to the suppliers which may
give you buying power on some other you
know another thing that happens in
desperate times is like I'll buy your
strawberries but next week when I buy
the squash or you know can I get a 20%
discount yes now you're winning twice
now you're doing something super often
you're just got so far more Joe
when we film you making it it's
super-fun and then everybody wants to
try that soup this weekend or tomorrow
or tonight he should start a text
messaging system or email against it as
well we use Facebook at first to build
awareness but then I don't want to keep
paying them he has the text now he's
like hey guys the flash Friday the
Facebook flash Friday food is farmer Joe
still stuck with those peppers during
last week we did this sauce this week
we're doing the pizzas out like you know
so I'm going way I would do it is not
more that you're slinging dealmaker it's
that you were creative you know with my
passion for food I've come up with a
great concoction of yam that's right yam
juice Babbage just pumped because he
knows it's gonna be a good piece of
content so no you don't see this part of
me with a lot of small businesses here
in Chattanooga big strategy of mine in
the southeast is to do more business
with small businesses so a hit up Peter
media's website if you feel that but
like the whole Alabama Florida Georgia
Louisiana like this is like we're gonna
use this office to really start drilling
it and he's kind of 25k to 250 K scopes
where we're just like a guardian a
mentor like we're breaking our own
business because we think there's a need
and it feels good like you know I don't
know if you just saw the fire and I'm
sure he'll edit it but like there's a
different hi for me
help that's what I did help my dad small
business I just know what to do when you
don't have a whole lot of money anybody
this week would you share with us the
names of the people
the senator no I would probably not
choose to do that publicly here I think
that might be what this is all about
your right to privacy I just want to say
one thing it's super fascinating that we
love to blame technology for our actions
the right to privacy absolutely matters
but that's not what the conversation is
about like like our choice like our
choices we don't see any ads that don't
have a like people don't like wasting
money like these people only get it we
love blaming technology side and
reference to I guess does much more fun
than blaming ourselves
dude how are you
[Music]
Davi I just wanted to say thank old on
one second said I just want to say
thanks I'm Nick from Bowling Green I was
how are you yes yes that's great some
real pleasure man yeah I was like hoping
you might come out here came out I
really hope so a pleasure to meet you
take care thank you so much my pleasure
what's up vlog great day here with my
homies from Chattanooga office headed to
the team dinner now a great day of
meetings business just kind of quit
incredible call with AJ just now about
fader sports like we've been invited to
the green room with Josh Jackson who's
gonna be a first rounder so if you're
watching the NFL Draft you're gonna see
me which is gonna be funny because I'm
definitely gonna have culture and do
something bigger this like you know live
streaming get kicked out or something
anyway nonetheless excited Fritta yeah
yeah the dinner we're having now at the
team which is always a highlight for me
when I'm in new gun I don't like the
sunsets am I like like I'm when it comes
to visually same things I'm like
fundamentally not me there's nothing on
earth that I want to say like I'm the
worst when it comes like travel like I
don't want to go to a single port
there's nothing I want to see nothing
yeah not one thing lay on the beach it
like do like for me nothing nothing is
the best like to me Beach and like do
nothing is like everything like it's
like yeah I don't want commodities the
only thing that I think with the only
thing that even begins and I would say
it's 1% is like the pyramids might be
interesting just cuz I'm like that's a
crazy [ __ ] but they were able to do that
like you know just rainbows there no my
mother's death
Tibo by the way so drive I will I will
tell you that TiVo tebow out of every
technology in the history of my life in
my life internet included TiVo was the
one that took me the longest to
comprehend I was like I couldn't put the
pieces together like what like you grew
up your whole life and you're like I'm
like what I can pause normal T like I'm
just like like wait what I'm thinking
pee during a Jets game like I just
couldn't wrap my head around it however
or you can make 70 I'm gonna go pretty
extreme for 130 that range talking about
skiing water polo wine I'm [ __ ]
fascinated by it man because I think I
think as people start learning more
about e-commerce as Amazon and spot
Shopify made commerce longtail as social
media makes media longtail I think as a
business owner that wants to build a big
Empire I love the fact that for all 8:19
network at Vayner like if that's what
they choose that's cool I think that's
super amazing so I think I think we hear
it being back to like technology and
changes and we're like well so few
people are gonna be but I don't think
that's the right argument the right
argument is not me or or Jenner's or
like oh like the you know the the people
that are with millions of fans
it's what's the Mendoza line because I
think eventually people realize wait if
you keep your expenses down and this is
why I'm fascinated by cities and
Chattanooga no tax this is like making
eighty eight here selling through
Shopify and getting shoutouts from
brands is a totally different life and I
know some of you lived it in New York
with us right then making 150
seven working at Vayner in New York and
Kama you're your own boss you talk about
the one thing you love in a strawberry
shortcake you talk about you love
strawberry shortcake
she's your favorite and that's what you
get to talk about 24 hours a day I think
it's super cool things like college debt
and things like doing what you love will
become more practical and I think that
one of the reasons I want to be Pro
employee and like all this is I want to
get my pattern recognition down for 20
years from now because the requirements
of having good people work for you will
be greater and greater and greater
because none of us grew up with that
expectation and it's not deep in our DNA
but they they will yeah we were we are
brainwashed in our current alternative
like like people really thought College
was a good idea Lincoln they're like all
of you in here at URI just thought it
was a good idea it wasn't a good idea
well now it was a great idea if the
following happened your parents paid for
it you had fun but if you're not part of
that not as interesting
I wanna take you places that you may
never be
[Music]